[FANFARE PLAYS]
- Good morning, I am Liz Cohen.
I'm dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study,
and I am delighted to welcome
you to Radcliffe Day 2018.
Radcliffe Day is always exciting
and a highlight of the year.
But it is especially
so for me this year.
I will be stepping
down at the end of June
to return to the
History Department
after seven wonderful years
as dean of the Radcliffe
Institute.
Recognizing--
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Thank you very much.
Recognizing inspiring leaders
with a Radcliffe medal
has been one of the very
best parts of my job.
Today we honor a remarkable
public servant, Hillary Rodham
Clinton.
[APPLAUSE]
And I am pleased to have
such a fantastic crowd
joining me to do that.
There are nearly 2,000 of us
here today in two tents, one
in Radcliffe Yard, the
other across the street
in Greenleaf Yard, making this
our largest Radcliffe Day ever.
Many others are
watching online, and I'd
like to extend a
special welcome to them.
This afternoon
starting at 12:30,
we will celebrate Secretary
Clinton's achievements
and award her the
Radcliffe Medal.
Former Secretary of State
and 2001 Radcliffe medalist
Madeleine Albright will
offer a personal tribute.
And Secretary Clinton will
then engage in conversation
with our own Maura Healey,
a graduate of the Harvard
Radcliffe Class of 1992.
[APPLAUSE]
And for those of you not from
Massachusetts, our attorney
general.
But first it is our
tradition to kick off
Radcliffe Day with a panel
discussion on a topic close
to our honoree's head and heart.
This morning's
theme in recognition
of Hillary Clinton's service
as US Secretary of State
from 2009 to 2013 is
America's role in the world.
What has it been, what is it
now, and what should it be?
We titled our panel Toward
a New Global Architecture
to recall major policy
speeches that Secretary Clinton
delivered in 2009 and
2010 at the Council
on Foreign Relations.
In those speeches, Clinton
enumerated important challenges
that face the United
States, including conflicts
in the Middle East,
violent extremism,
nuclear proliferation,
climate change, and disease.
And she called for a
new global architecture
that would enable
solutions to those issues
through collective action on
a global scale with the United
States taking a bold
leadership role.
These challenges demanded
an architecture in which,
and I quote her, "States
have clear incentives
to cooperate and live up
to their responsibilities
as well as strong disincentives
to sit on the sidelines
or sow discord and
division," end quote.
In constructing this
new architecture,
Clinton argued,
"the United States
can, must, and will lead in
this new century," end quote.
Resharpening its
tools to undertake
what she called a smart
power approach that
transcends simplistic
distinctions
between hard and soft power.
Instead, the US should
implement a nimble statecraft
that strategically combines
goals like economic development
with, in her words, "good
old-fashioned diplomacy."
The challenges Secretary
Clinton grappled
with almost 10 years ago
are still very much with us.
And many of them feel
only more urgent today.
All of them require
global solutions
in a world that is more
interconnected than ever
before.
As a result of our
interdependence,
even challenges that once
seem solidly domestic
have become increasingly
global in nature.
Diseases don't respect
national borders.
We have seen this in the cases
of H1N1, SARS, MIRS, Zika,
and the 2013 to
2016 Ebola epidemic.
Climate change has been a
global issue since we first
started talking about it.
We know that we share
a single atmosphere,
but global cooperation
to reduce emissions
continues to prove challenging.
The threat posed by
non-state violent extremist
groups such as ISIS, Boko
Haram, the Taliban, al-Qaeda,
and al-shabaab similarly
transcends political frontiers
and demands global cooperation.
So, too, does the
massive displacement
of millions of people who
are refugees from conflicts
in Syria, South Sudan, Somalia,
Afghanistan, and elsewhere.
In the face of these and many
other new and still evolving
global challenges, it
is imperative to return
to Secretary Clinton's question
and probe the current state
of the global
architecture and the role
the United States is
playing in it hopefully
as a force for
peaceful stability,
for moral leadership, and
human including women's rights,
for greater
worldwide prosperity,
and for solving
formidable world problems.
In seeking solutions
moreover, we
must also avoid a growing
danger that Madeleine Albright
recently warned about, the
rising tide of authoritarianism
around the world from Russia to
the Philippines to Venezuela.
As Albright wrote
last month, we may
be encouraged that most
people in most countries
still want to live
freely and in peace,
but there is no
ignoring the storm
clouds that have gathered.
And she continued, "If one were
to draft a script chronicling
fascism's resurrection,
the abdication
of America's moral
leadership would
make a credible first
scene," end quote.
Recently, it seems
that the United States
is lurching from one
crisis to another
whether it's the war in
Syria, the nuclear standoffs
with North Korea
and Iran, or the US
exit from international
agreements like the Paris
Climate Change Accord
and trade alliances.
The president has called for an
America First foreign policy,
but it bears asking what America
first means in today's world.
Over a century since Woodrow
Wilson used the slogan
in his 1916 re-election
campaign to assuage fears
of US involvement in World
War I and so many decades
since the America
First committee
promoted its opposition to the
US's entry into World War II.
In today's environment
of global challenges,
massive international
trade, population mobility,
technological transfer,
and high-tech threats,
can United States
really go it alone?
And if and when it does,
what does America First
convey to the rest of the
world, friends and foes alike.
Our panel this morning provides
an exceptional opportunity
to step back and begin
to piece together
the current state of the global
architecture and the role
that the United States
is assuming within it.
What do recent American actions
and reactions add up to?
Where are we headed?
What kind of
expertise is needed?
And how should we as
individuals and as a country
think about America's
role and responsibilities
in this seemingly ever
more precarious world?
We could have no better guide
to this important discussion
than Nicholas Burns, who is the
Roy and Barbara Goodman Family
Professor of the
practice of diplomacy
and international relations
at the Harvard Kennedy School
where he also leads the
future of diplomacy project
and the project on Europe and
the Transatlantic relationship.
Nicks Burns is director of
the Aspen Strategy Group,
and he sits on too many boards
and advisory groups to name.
But before joining
the Kennedy School,
Burns was a member of the US
Foreign Service for 27 years,
including as US
ambassador to Greece,
US ambassador to NATO, and from
2005 to 2008 as undersecretary
of state for Political Affairs
where he led negotiations
on the US India civil
nuclear agreement,
Iran's nuclear
program, and much more.
I am enormously grateful to Nick
for taking on this assignment
today and for all the help he
has given me over the past year
as we plan together for today.
He will introduce our
panelists and then he
will engage them in
discussion, so please join me
in warmly welcoming
Nicholas Burns.
[APPLAUSE]
- Liz, thank you.
Good morning, everybody
on this beautiful morning
in Radcliffe Yard.
We have a lot of people to
thank for this tremendous day.
But there is one woman who
has led this Institute,
and she's walking
right in front of me.
[APPLAUSE]
She has led it with strength
and dynamism and passion
and an unfailing belief that
reason and empirical thought
and the pursuit of knowledge
represent the highest values
of Radcliffe Institute and
of Harvard University .
She has expanded
Radcliffe's public programs.
She has added new
professorships.
If you take a look around
this glorious Radcliffe Yard,
she's brought art
and art installations
into the heart of the yard.
And she's embraced our president
Drew Faust vision of one
Harvard may it ever be so.
I think after seven
extraordinary years,
she deserves another
rousing round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
It is a privilege for
all of us to be here
with the most extraordinary,
most accomplished public
servant that we have had in this
country in a long, long time,
Hillary Rodham Clinton.
[APPLAUSE]
As an attorney from another
law school, as a civic leader,
as an advocate for
children for the poor
and for women, as First Lady,
as United States senator,
as our secretary
of state, she has
served with exemplary
determination and intelligence
and resilience and courage.
And as we begin our
discussion today
of a very complex subject--
what is America's relationship
to the rest of the world, what
is America trying to
achieve in that world--
we will have Secretary
Clinton's prodigious record
of accomplishment
to help guide us.
From her first national speech
on a stage 10 miles west
of here at Wellesley
College in 1969
to her pathbreaking
exhortation in Beijing
at a seminal conference in
1995 that human rights are
women's rights and women's
rights are human rights--
[APPLAUSE]
To her untiring support for
the United States military
when she was a senator
from the state of New York
to her four a
challenging consequential
and often, I'm sure,
exhausting years
as our 67th secretary
of state, she
has given with every ounce
of persistence and hope
and determination, she
showed us how America can
be great on the world stage.
And I think she may
exemplify better than just
about anybody I know Theodore
Roosevelt's belief that it's
not the critic who counts,
that the credit belongs,
in this case, to the woman
who is in the arena, who
is in the public square, who
is in the middle of the action,
and, in Roosevelt's words, who
knows the great enthusiasms,
the great devotions, who spends
herself in a worthy cause
so, as TR said so memorably,
her place shall never
be with those cold and timid
souls who know neither victory
nor defeat.
She has been in the
arena for all of us
for the United States for
her entire adult life.
As secretary of state, she
steered America's response
to the Arab revolutions.
She stood up to the Chinese in
2010 on the South China Sea.
She stood up to a
truculent Vladimir Putin
in Eastern Europe.
She ended--
[APPLAUSE]
And read her memoirs and
you'll get the detail on that.
She ended a bitter
and bloody rocket war
between Israel and Hezbollah.
And she managed
nuclear arms reductions
to make this a safer world.
She also-- and Anne-Marie will
talk about this I'm sure today
because Anne-Marie
was a big part of it--
she pioneered an important
conceptual change
about how we should
think about diplomacy.
It was her insight that
American diplomacy,
American development,
and American defense
must all be linked in one
cohesive national strategy.
And in contrast to the
absolutely deplorable lack
of support for our diplomats
over the last year,
she inspired our diplomats
to represent the United
States, our young
women, our young men,
all around the world.
So this panel's meeting
at an important moment
where America's greatness
on the global stage
is being challenged as never
before, what has made America
an exceptional nation,
the indispensable nation
as President Clinton and
Secretary Albright used
to remind us, what has made us
the undisputed global nation,
a great nation since the Second
World War to 9/11 and the years
since?
We had to be an
outward looking people.
We had to understand
that we had to be
part of the global
comments, engage
with the rest of the
world, not digging
a moat around the
country and pulling up
the drawbridge bridges but
actually being in the world
as a leader.
Our closest friends
and our allies
lament the fact that we are
very far from that vision now.
And it's important to remember
a little bit of history.
After World War II,
every president--
until President Trump--
every president, Republican
and Democrat, believed that
our power and purpose was based
on enduring foundations,
our alliances
like NATO, free
trade, a willingness
to keep America's doors open
to immigration and refugees,
a willingness to lead in
the defense of human rights
and of democracy and
of democratic ideals
when they're
challenged as Madeleine
has written about
in her new book.
But the cruel reality is this.
We are now retreating
in all of those areas.
Our government has abandoned the
Paris Climate Change Accords,
abandoned three major
trade agreements,
abandoned the Iran nuclear deal,
abandoned our historic position
on Jerusalem, and may now
be abandoning the pursuit
of diplomacy in North Korea.
We're no longer leading in
the tradition of Marshall
and Acheson, of Dulles and
Herter, of James A. Baker,
of Madeleine Albright, of Colin
Powell, of Condoleezza Rice,
and Hillary Rodham Clinton.
Winston Churchill visited
Harvard and Radcliffe
in September 1943, and he
addressed the students here
at this university.
And it was an epochal
time in a terrible war.
It was just after the Allied
victories at Stalingrad and El
Alamein just after
the commencement
of the Italian campaign.
The US was taking the
metaphorical baton
of leadership from Britain as
the world's strongest power.
And at that critical
moment when so much rested
on our shoulders,
here's what Churchill
said to the students of
Harvard and Radcliffe.
He said, "The price of
greatness is responsibility."
The price of greatness
responsibility.
To be truly great in our
time, the United States
needs to lead with
strategic purpose,
with respect for other
countries and other peoples,
with dignity, with
dedication to help
advance justice and democracy
and peace in the world.
And we have strayed so
far from that mission
under Donald Trump's chaotic,
weak, and fearful leadership
of our country.
But in her life and
work, Hillary Clinton
has been all about
responsibility.
We're fortunate to
have the example
of that responsible leadership
today to help guide us
and to renew America's
greatness as we move forward.
Such an honor to be here.
And we have four very
distinguished panelists.
Starting at the far end
of the table on my left,
Anne-Marie Slaughter,
former Director of Policy
Planning at the State Department
for Secretary Clinton,
a graduate of Harvard Law
School, now president and CEO
of the New America Foundation.
Meghan O'Sullivan, former
Deputy National Security Adviser
to President George W. Bush
for Iraq and Afghanistan.
How's that for a
tough challenge.
Now the Jeane Kirkpatrick
Professor of the Practice
of international
affairs and my colleague
at the Harvard Kennedy School.
David Ignatius,
Washington Post columnist,
foreign policy thought
leader, spy novelist--
read The Quantum
Spy, his latest--
a graduate of Harvard College.
And Michele Flournoy,
former undersecretary
of defense for policy, a
graduate of Harvard College
back in a reunion year,
now managing director
of west exec advisors.
Let's get to our discussion.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So, Anne-Marie,
we'll lead with you.
We'll have a discussion here
for the next hour or so.
We're going to arrange widely.
We also have a lot of
questions from you.
Liz and her staff
solicited your questions.
I have them here.
I will inject those questions,
Liz, at the right moment.
I thought it was right
to lead with Anne-Marie.
In her position as state
working for Secretary Clinton,
she had to look out
over the whole world
and think about our
broad national strategy.
I just suggested,
Anne-Marie, that we are--
that we've fallen
from grace, that we
don't have a strategic purpose,
that we're not leading,
that we've abandoned
allies and trade
and immigration and refugees.
Agree?
Disagree?
[LAUGHS]
- Well, when I was a
law professor here,
that would have been known
as a leading question.
- Yes.
- But let me just
begin by saying
how honored I am to be here.
And I have to say when I walked
in with that trumpet fanfare,
I thought I was at
the royal wedding.
But the hats aren't
quite as good.
I also am here as an
example of a glass ceiling
that Secretary Clinton broke.
I was the first woman Director
of Policy Planning, which
is the big think job in
the State Department,
and it was founded when
George Marshall asked
George Kennan to
take it on, which
is the legacy none of us
have ever lived up to.
But Secretary Clinton
very deliberately
wanted to prove to the world--
I hope she did, I'm not
going to claim that-- but she
wanted to prove that a
woman could hold that job,
and that's why I'm
sitting here today.
I would go anywhere.
[APPLAUSE]
So, Nick, to answer
your question,
we are not leading in the world.
But I want to frame my
answer in the context
of a message the American
people have been sending us
and we in this room and
this great university
and all the great
universities I've been part of
and Washington
are not listening.
Ever since the end
of the Cold War,
the candidate that
said I don't want
to continue being
the global hegemon
and spending our money
that way has won.
In 1992, President
George HW Bush,
the hero of ending the
Cold War, the most literate
foreign policy president we
had had in a very long time,
lost to this governor
from the south
who didn't really talk
about foreign policy a lot
in his election.
He said, "It's the
economy, stupid."
And I as a governor
of Arkansas know
what to do for this country.
In 2000, his vice president,
another southerner,
who was an extraordinary
global diplomat--
he had led the work with Russia.
He had been all over
the world, and he
ran against another southern
governor, who basically
said I don't know
much about the world,
but we need a kinder,
gentler nation.
Guess who won?
In 2004, similar pattern.
2008, John McCain ran.
I am not of John McCain's party,
but I have enormous respect
for John McCain.
John McCain has stood up for
the best of our traditions.
He stood up against--
[APPLAUSE]
I will never forget
in the aughts
when I was here
teaching at the time--
when suddenly people were
actually talking about torture
was OK for our country.
It was necessary, and
we're hearing that again.
And John McCain led
that fight, and he
had been obviously a
participant in the great--
in great global
events of our time.
But against Barack Obama,
he was the globalist,
and there was a
senator from Illinois
who talked about bringing
this country together,
who rejected the Iraq war.
Guess who won.
And I don't think I have to
tell you the story of 2016,
but it is the most horrific
example of somebody saying
it's--
I don't want this role in
the world and somebody else
saying we must have
this role in the world,
and we're not winning.
So I just want to say
a couple of things
about how it is
time to stopped--
to stop rejecting
that message or trying
to instruct those who send it on
how they really are misguided.
It's time to listen
to that message.
And in many ways
they're telling us
something Secretary
Clinton taught me
because one of the things I
had the privilege of doing
was working with her on her
first big development speech.
And she said to us--
she tasked a group of us
to think about what should
American development policy be.
And she said it
cannot be charity.
I need to tell the
person in Detroit
why I am spending American
taxpayers' dollars
in Africa and not in Detroit.
And I must have an account that
makes sense to that person.
We need to think about how
we can lead in the world
and in a different way.
And we-- to start, we have to
recognize that right now, we
are less the global hegemon
than the global hypocrite.
We are preaching values of
democracy and universal values
we are not practicing at home.
We are preaching prosperity and
our country is falling apart.
I live on Amtrak.
I know of what I speak.
But second, we need to make
foreign policy and diplomacy
the work of many,
many more people
than those of us on this
panel and in this university
and in Washington.
LA appointed the
first deputy mayor
for International
Affairs that person--
I'm proud to say
she's a woman-- is
former ambassador in the Obama
administration Nina Hachigian,
she's in Los Angeles
doing foreign affairs.
Chicago has 28 sister
city relationships.
If you ever walk from
O'Hare to the Hilton, which
I've done many,
many, many times,
it's a Hall of United Nations.
28 nations flags
hang in that walkway.
Cities across the country
are playing as important role
in fighting terrorism
in climate change.
President Trump pulled
out, but the cities
of the United States, led by
Mayor Bloomberg, stood up.
And we are going to
meet our commitments
through those city's efforts
and the efforts of universities,
businesses, nonprofit leaders,
faith leaders, all of us.
So what I would say to come
back to Nick's questions--
just a slight digression--
we have to first of
all listen to Americans
who are saying when we were
under mortal threat in the Cold
War fighting the Soviet
Union nuclear weapon
to nuclear weapon--
and let us hope that day
doesn't come fully again.
We're back to
fighting Russia but
in a different configuration.
In those days, we
would bear any price--
pay any price and
bear any burden,
but today we need to pay more
attention to what is happening
in the United States.
So we need to learn how to
lead because I deeply believe--
to paraphrase
Secretary Albright--
we are an indispensable nation.
We are not the only
one, but we are
a nation that needs to
be at the global table.
And when we are, the
world is a better place.
But to get there, we have
to listen to Americans.
We have to learn how to
lead in a different way
and to not only have the great
diplomats like Nick Burns
but to have all those people who
are not in the Foreign Service
but who are representing
America in the world
be a part of who we are and
what we do in the world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Meghan, another way
to ask this question--
I wanted you to speak to this
as well as you are a Republican.
There's been a consensus
since the late 40s
among Republicans and Democrats
in foreign and defense policy
the way we haven't had
in domestic policy.
It's all those things
that Anne-Marie and I
have talked about that Madeline
has written in her new book.
What's happened to
that consensus, and--
can I just-- and to your party?
And is your party
divided on that?
- Great.
Thanks for the softball.
[LAUGHS]
Good morning, everyone.
And like others,
I'd like to begin
by saying what an honor
it is to be here today
for such a great
day for Radcliffe
and for such a
wonderful occasion
to honor Secretary Clinton.
Unlike many others
on this stage,
I have not had the opportunity
to work for Secretary Clinton,
but I have benefited from
her career as a citizen most
importantly and all the good
that she's done but also
as a woman because she has
fought many fights that I
will not have to fight
because she did that.
So I want to thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And I hope that I can
answer your question, Nick,
and inject a little
bit of optimism
simply because there is the
risk that we're going to depress
ourselves on this topic.
To state what
others have stated--
but I think it's very
important to note--
is that over the last 70 years,
the world has really prospered.
This has been a period of
unprecedented prosperity
and peace on large
account because
of the web of
institutions and norms
that have underpinned a lot of
what has gone on in the world,
and the US has just been
the most critical actor,
not only in constructing that
web of institutions and norms
but in defending it.
And I think any
president at this moment
would have a challenge with this
order, with rejuvenating it,
with bringing it
up to the moment.
The world is very different
than it was 70 years ago,
and I think any
president would have
the challenge of modernizing
this international order as we
call it and dealing
with new challenges
to that order be it China, be
it global disease, whatever
the case may be.
Unfortunately, we're not
having that conversation, which
would be much wonkier
but much more welcome
and that would be how to reform
this international order.
We're having a
conversation about
are we still invested in it.
And as others have
suggested, we really--
despite Anne-Marie's laying out
the electoral map over the last
couple of decades--
we have the first
president in office
who has questioned
openly whether it
is in America's
interest to continue
to be the defender of this
particular role in the world.
So others maybe
didn't campaign on it,
but once that person came
into the Oval Office,
the imperative of American
leadership, I think,
has always been clear.
So we are at a unique
moment with a president who
does question whether
this as good for America.
And this is concerning
because it takes leadership,
particularly in a moment where
there are lots of anxieties
about globalization.
It takes leadership not
only from the Oval Office
but I would say most
importantly from the Oval Office
to build and
maintain a consensus
within our own country about
the importance of America
playing this role
and to make sure
that consensus is not based
just on people on the stage
or people in this tent
but that it is one that
embraces elites and non-elites.
It embraces, as Anne-Maria
said, all parts of our country.
To get to your
question specifically
about the Republican
Party, and here's
where I'm injecting
optimism, I would
say it is still
important to distinguish
between the president
and the Republican Party.
Many Republicans-- and I would
consider myself one of them--
don't really see
him as a Republican.
And he has departed
from very traditional
core Republican
values and policies
in very, very fundamental ways.
Now I think this is
a little disguised
by the tax cuts because you have
seen the Republican leadership
and really rallied behind
the president in this regard.
But if we look at the menu
of policies and attitudes
and orientations,
I still think there
is a pretty significant
gap between the president
and the bulk of
the party when it
comes to international affairs.
I could go through
the long list,
but in the interest
of time I won't.
I'll simply say, take
trade for instance.
The president's been
very vocal about trade.
This is one of the things
that has been very consistent,
one of the few things that
has been very consistent
in his policy agenda.
He is not someone who extols
the value of free trade.
He openly embraced protectionism
in his inaugural speech.
But I think there's still
a very strong support
for free trade
among Republicans,
among American business.
And I would say, if
you look at polls,
most Americans still are
more in favor of free trade
than they are against it.
And so I think there is
still a lot to work with.
And that's true for
alliances as well.
Americans like alliances,
Democrat, Republican.
And just because the
president doesn't
seem to value them as much
as many of us would like
doesn't mean that we no longer
have a national foundation
for these things.
So again I won't go through the
whole list of areas in which I
think we still have
a strong foundation
and a strong national
interest, but I
do think we are at a moment of
a crisis of leadership, which
is why it's such a
wonderful day to honor
some national
leadership in this tent.
- Meghan, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Just to support
something that Meghan
said about Republican
leadership in Congress,
it was Ed Royce, Bob
Corker, Lindsey Graham,
who stood up to President
Trump on funding
for the State Department, for
instance, over the last year.
Republicans restored
the funding,
so I think there is this
dynamic on the Hill.
A lot of questions here
from the audience, Michele,
about our challenges
with Vladimir Putin.
And you've been a
leading defense official
for our country for a long time.
He invaded Georgia in 2008.
He invaded, occupied, and
annexed Crimea in 2014.
8,000 Russian troops
in eastern Ukraine
pressuring the Baltic states.
Are we back to containment?
We're rebuilding American
armored presence in Eastern
Europe, and what would
you advise President Trump
to do about Putin,
Eastern Europe,
the defense of democracy?
- Well, let me just
say it's a pleasure
to be back at Radcliffe where
I have many fond memories.
I was saying particularly rowing
for under Radcliffe colors
on the Charles River.
[APPLAUSE]
And such an honor to be a part
of a panel honoring Secretary
Clinton.
I had the great good
fortune of being trapped
in a windowless room with
her for many, many hours,
The Situation Room, and
just such a privilege
to watch such an extraordinary
public servant guide
US foreign policy to be smart
and strategic and in the best
interests of America
and Americans,
so thank you for being here
and thank you for letting
me to be part of this.
So Vladimir Putin and Russia.
I think it's important
to understand
where Putin is coming from.
Putin represents a deep
sense of grievance in Russia,
that Russia since the
end of the Cold War
has lost its
geopolitical position,
has presided over a
declining economy,
has had a failed
experiment in democracy,
has really become a
middling power as opposed
to a great power.
And so Putin is
determined to reassert
Russia as a great power using
just about any means necessary.
He is determined to recreate
a sphere of influence
around Russia's borders.
And most importantly
for us, he is also
determined to undermine
democracy as a model,
be it in Central
and Eastern Europe
or here in the United
States, because the biggest
threat to Vladimir Putin is the
potential for true democracy
to re-emerge in Russia.
Despite the relative
economic weakness
of Russia compared to its
European counterparts,
Putin has actually played
a limited hand very well.
He is reverted to
the KGB playbook
and used a whole range
of asymmetric means
to try to advance Russian
interests and influence--
intelligence operations,
propaganda, disinformation,
cyber attacks, little
green men, meaning
paid Russian proxies,
and so forth.
And we've seen this in
Crimea, in Ukraine, previously
in Georgia.
We've seen it in
the meddling that
preceded the meddling
in our elections
the meddling in Eastern and
Central European elections
and so forth.
So I think-- to
answer your question--
I think unfortunately despite
some very serious work
at resetting the relationship
with by investing in areas
where we had common
interests like arms
control, nonproliferation,
counter-terrorism, climate
change, and so many
others, Putin has really
taken a very sharp turn.
And now Russia is
presenting real challenges
to the United States, if not in
some cases, an actual threat.
So what do we do.
I think the most important
step we need to take
is to reestablish a very
clear policy of deterrence.
We need to clarify
where the lines are
with Putin with regard
to us and with regard
to our European allies.
First and foremost, we
have to deter meddling
in the next round
of elections being--
this fall in 2018 where there's
already evidence of preparation
of that and certainly in 2020.
One of the challenges of
President Trump's denial
of this issue is for
his own personal reasons
and his own concerns about
the legitimacy of his election
is that the United
States does not
have a strategy for preventing
this from happening again.
This is the biggest threat
to our democracy that exists.
We cannot go through an election
where Russian meddling actually
calls into question the
results of the vote tallies.
Although they didn't
do that last time,
we know that they surveyed at
least 30 to 35 of our state
electoral systems to know how
to do it if they needed to.
We need to prevent that.
It means investing
in the resilience
of our electoral systems at
the state and local level.
Fortunately,
Congress has finally
allocated some funds
for that, but we
need to really engage the
best of the private sector
to help state and local
electoral officials improve
the strength of their system.
But we also need to clearly
communicate to Putin
that there will be no
kidding costs if he
crosses that line again.
We also need to clarify
deterrents in Europe.
It is completely unfathomable
and unacceptable that a United
States president would go
to his first NATO summit
and refuse to re-articulate
America's security
commitment to NATO.
This is the alliance
that invoked
Article V for the first
time in our history
because we were under
attack on 9/11 by al-Qaeda.
How is it possible that an
American president would
hesitate to make a commitment
to the most important set
of allies we have in the
world and a huge source
of strategic advantage
for the United States.
So we need to clarify
in word and in deed
that we are there to
support deterrence
and reassurance in Europe.
We also need to
make sure that we
continue to support democracy
programs and resilience
programs.
There's real threat to democracy
in Central and Eastern Europe.
We need to do better at
countering Russian propaganda
and information operations
in Europe and here.
And lastly, we need to invest
to ensure that we maintain
the military edge
that we will need
in certain critical areas like
cyber and electronic warfare
and precision strike to again
underwrite deterrence and make
sure that Vladimir Putin does
not miscalculate and think
that he can cross the border
into Europe or cross a border
and threaten us militarily.
So let me stop there.
- Michele, a quick
follow up before we--
[APPLAUSE]
Before we talk about the
Middle East and North Korea,
two perilous subjects.
Last week, really one of the
only bipartisan committees
these days in Congress,
the Senate Select Committee
on Intelligence,
led by a Republican,
Richard Burr of North Carolina,
and a Democrat, the vice chair,
Mark Warner of Virginia, issued
a report after more than a year
of study and
hearings saying they
had no doubt the Russians
interfered in the elections,
no doubt they interfered on
behalf of candidate Trump.
Are we ready for 2018?
You talked about--
are we ready for 2020?
Is it up to the
attorney generals
have our states to try to
fashion these defense policies?
Are we going to get
leadership from Washington?
- We are not ready,
particularly for 2018.
I think that there will
be some candidates who
take the steps necessary to
make sure their own cyber
security is up to speed,
but my biggest worry
is again our electoral
infrastructure
is operated at the
state and local level it
is as diverse and differentiate
as you could possibly imagine.
There's been no
leadership on the part
of the federal government.
Until now, there's been very
little money available to help.
I've been part of an
effort to mobilize the tech
community to-- on
a pro bono basis
to go out and offer
advice, services, counsel,
help to any candidate,
any state election
official, any local election
official who wants to build
the resilience of their system.
The most important
thing we need to do
is to have an audit trail
no matter what happens.
Whether we go back
to a paper audit
trail or an encrypted
electronic audit trail,
we must ensure that when we
have an election in 2020,
we actually know with
confidence who won.
And we need to also
communicate to Vladimir Putin
that we will be coming after
the things that he care-- he
and his oligarchs
care about most
if he crosses that line again.
- Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
So now we're going to
take on the Middle East.
At Harvard, we have
courses where we
do this over 3 and 1/2 months.
We're going to do this
and ask Meg and David, who
both know a lot after decades of
experience in the Middle East.
And here's the question
I pose to both of you.
I think, Meghan, are
going to take the lead,
and David will speak second.
We've just come out of a
very bloody war in Iraq.
We're back in the fight against
the Islamic State, which
is ending.
We're in Syria.
Iran's a regional troublemaker.
We're out of the
Iran nuclear deal.
The question is, is there
an overarching strategy
that our government should have
to deal with this because we've
been the most important
outside power since the 1970s
in the Middle East?
I keep asking you the most
challenging questions,
but I know you can answer them.
- Well, there's plenty
to go around I think.
Let me say there--
it's interesting-- your question
is interesting because it
implies really two things.
One, does the US still have an
interest in being in the Middle
East in the way that it has
been for the previous decades,
and, two, are we
capable of devising
a strategy that meets
the enormous challenges
of that part of the world.
So let me take him both quickly
and turn first this question
of is it really in the US
interest for us to be there.
And I get this question a lot.
I'm sure many of you do.
And I understand that
people are hoping
you'll say no, it's no longer
in our interest to be there.
One, there's the
fatigue that has
gone on as a result of
the engagements in Iraq
and elsewhere.
But also there's this
new idea that we're
more self-sufficient in
energy, and therefore we
don't need to be
in the Middle East
because we don't
need their energy.
And that is a big change
in the relationship.
And I hate to throw cold
water on these ideas,
but, in fact, it still is
very much in the US interests
to be engaged in the
Middle East and to be
invested in a better outcome
for that part of the world.
There are energy reasons
why that still is true
regardless of how much
oil the US produces,
which I could go into, but I'll
save that for another time.
But there's also a broad
range of non-energy interests
that are going to keep us there.
And there's also a need to throw
cold water on a related idea,
and that is maybe
the Middle East
would be better off without
American engagement.
We certainly have
demonstrated that we
are capable of making many
serious mistakes in that part
of the world, and wouldn't
that region be better
without the United States.
I can say pretty definitively
when we look at Syria today,
despite the great advice of
Secretary Clinton and others,
that is with the Middle East
looks like without a lot of US
engagement.
It is not obviously
a better place
either from the perspective
of people living in the Middle
East or for US interests.
You think about
how destabilizing
that conflict has been to our
European allies, the risks
that it has posed to
the United States.
So I very squarely
put myself in the camp
of people who believe it is
still very much in America's
interests regardless of how
difficult it is to stay engaged
in that part of the world.
The question about
strategy is harder.
And I know David will go into
this in even greater detail.
But let me just
say, of course, this
is a very, very heterogeneous
part of the world
despite maybe some
of the stereotypes.
It's a very varied
part of the world.
So we're not going to
have one strategy that
actually addresses
all of the challenges
in that part of the world.
But we do need two things,
which are currently
in very short supply, if we are
going to be better positioned
to respond to the challenges
in that part of the world
and to meet them.
And those two things
are first, I would say,
is a much greater appreciation
for how interconnected
the challenges are there.
So they're not the same,
but they're very related.
So take, for
example, the decision
to withdraw from the
Iran nuclear deal.
Now, this decision,
whatever you think of it,
it makes our challenges in
other parts of the region,
not just in Iran but in
much, much harder because
Iran is all over the region.
So if we give a reason for Iran
to oppose American interests,
not just on this narrow
but very significant
question of Iran's
nuclear ambitions,
this gives Iran the
incentive to challenge us
more in Iraq, in Syria, in
Yemen, vis a vis Saudi Arabia.
Really this creates more
obstacles to success.
So again, we need a
greater appreciation
for how these things
are all interrelated,
and that the assessments that
happen in this windowless room
really need to reflect that.
And secondly in a category of
potentially unpopular things
I will say today, I think
Americans need to get over--
and I know this is
impossible, which
is why I'm not a politician--
their aversion to-- call
it whatever we want--
but helping other countries
build institutions.
What has happened in the Middle
East in the last 10 years
is really the collapse
of the Arab state.
And to the extent that
there is such a thing
as a solution for that
part of the world,
it will be the rebuilding
of states in the Arab world.
Now, this is not to say
America should be rebuilding
these states, but America
has a real interest
and these states are rebuilt
in a way that reflects
the interest both
of their people
and of stability in the region.
And America has know how and
resources and a diplomatic heft
that's very important in the
rebuilding of these countries.
So again the aversion
to getting involved
in things that are difficult,
that require resources,
and that take a long
time, we will have
to tackle that head on if we are
going to be able to help a very
critical part of the world
have a better future,
which is essential to
our own future as well.
- Thank you, Meghan.
[APPLAUSE]
Meghan has written
a great new book
called A Windfall, which
looks at transformations
in the energy
industry worldwide,
which we highly recommend.
- I was going to complain that
you gave David's spy novel--
- I'm just trying to be--
I'm trying to be
fair and balanced.
Fair and balanced.
David, it's so great
to have you here.
I think all of us recognize your
deep experience in the Middle
East.
You were a foreign correspondent
there several decades ago.
You go back.
You've been in Syria.
You've been tracking this
unbelievable human tragedy
of the 12 million homeless,
the fractured state.
How do you make sense of this.
If you were to advise President
Trump, what should he be doing?
- Thank you, Nick, and the first
thing to say is that Syria--
but so much of the Middle East--
it's a tragedy.
We watch it.
We feel a sense of horror for
what's happened to people.
We struggle to think of
how we can affect that,
reduce the human cost, and we
have failed again and again.
And it's painful
and poignant so,
that's the first starting point.
In covering Secretary Clinton
when she was Secretary of State
and her Middle East views,
I was struck by two things
that I want to mention.
First, I think she was always
ready to use American power
to try to maintain the
conditions of security
and stability that
that region needs.
She understood that however
tired the United States
might be of its
involvement there,
the consequence
of our withdrawal
would be only
greater loss of life.
And that's what we've seen.
She also, as I remember,
was cautious about what
she wanted us to do.
She-- when the
Arab Spring swept,
the Arab world moved
from Tunisia and Egypt.
Secretary Clinton was within
the Obama administration
a voice for let's be careful.
Let's see if we can get an
orderly transition in Egypt
away from Hosni Mubarak,
then the president,
maybe let's take yes
for an answer when
he said on February 1, 2011,
that he was prepared to resign.
As I read that record, I
think Secretary Clinton
and her caution--
let's not go over
the waterfall here,
let's not throw this
up for revolution--
I think it looks very sensible.
A second thing that
sticks in my mind
is Secretary Clinton's
views about Syria
as this great tragedy
began to roll forward
as this country
began to come apart.
In 2012 as a columnist, I
was struggling to figure out
what do I think about this?
What's the right
thing to recommend?
I honestly didn't know.
So I did what journalists do.
I decided to do the
reporting, and I
snuck across the
Turkish border, was
smuggled by the Free Syrian
Army, as it was called,
and traveled to Aleppo.
It was the craziest thing I've
ever done as a journalist.
My wife still hasn't
really forgiven me for it.
But when I got out,
it was obvious to me
that the policies--
it was not then known
that Secretary Clinton
was advocating them
in secret in the situation
room-- but those policies
were correct.
What I wrote and what
she was arguing inside
was first Bashar al-assad
will never govern all of Syria
again.
It's not going to happen.
He's gone to war
with his own people.
Second, the Free Syrian
Army, these peoples
trying to create a
new country need help.
They're a mess and they
need the kind of help
that the US military
special forces can provide.
And three if we don't
do that, the extremists
who I already saw all over
Aleppo in northern Syria
will only get stronger.
And, of course, that was before
there was anything called ISIS.
And ISIS came and we were then
plunged into a much darker war,
but I think Secretary
Clinton got that right.
She argued it in
the administration.
I will believe
till my last breath
that this awful story
might have been different
if her advice had been followed.
Let me conclude just by offering
a brief snapshot of where
we are now in a
part of this policy.
Syria as a whole is in
catastrophic state failure.
But in the east of Syria--
east of the Euphrates
where our special forces have
delivered almost completely
on their commitment
to destroy ISIS,
you do see conditions
of stability.
The United States found a
way to deploy military power
with very few people.
It's basically been 2000
special forces in Syria,
motivated allies who want to
do the fighting themselves,
a small footprint an
extraordinary success.
East of the Euphrates, I've
traveled there three times
in the last two years, you see
people fleeing toward America
and its allies for security.
I'll close with just a deeply
disturbing image of what
we have done probably
without an alternative,
but we don't want to do again.
Traveling through Raqqa,
which was the capital
of the Islamic State, you see--
I was there two months ago--
you see a level of destruction
I have never seen
covering wars, conflicts
for more than 30 years.
It looks like the
pictures we remember
of the battle of Berlin at
the end of World War II.
It's a nightmare.
It tells you two things.
If you really mess with the
United States to the point
that we say we're going
to make a commitment
to degrade and destroy
your movement, we mean it.
And we have the ability
to bring to bear
a level of military
power that people just
have to take seriously.
And second, we don't
want to do that again.
And what I've come to think is
once a determined adversary is
in an urban area like
Raqqa, like these cities,
there really is no good
humane way to get them out.
So we have to with our
allies prevent that
from happening in
the first place,
but I think on these
questions, Secretary Clinton
came as close to getting
it right as anybody
I know at the top of government.
[APPLAUSE]
- Nick, if you'll just allow
me to make a very quick two
finger about this, I think
your point about Raqqa
and the devastation not only in
Syria but also in northern Iraq
is just incredible.
And your point
saying that America
has made the point
to the world if we
say we're going to destroy your
movement, this is what happens,
I think an even
stronger point would
be to be able to point to
those parts of the world
and say but we can help you
rebuild because that is where I
think the future of this
conflict in Syria and in Iraq
is going to go.
If those places are not
rebuilt in some fashion,
then we're going to
see this movie again.
Again, that doesn't mean
America going in and doing
all of the rebuilding
but marshaling
a lot of the diplomatic effort,
the economic resources I think
is going to be
absolutely critical.
- Anne-Marie.
- Just quickly, I
want again to tie
this back to domestic politics.
And again my thesis
is it is so important
to have these conversations,
but if we're not
thinking about domestic
policy politics,
we will continue having
these conversations
where we are lamenting
what is happening
and we're not connected
to the American people.
So just on Meghan's point
about state building,
and it goes to David's
point equally about the kind
of destruction and what
Secretary Clinton I think saw
was that we must focus
on the people as well
as the chessboard of politics.
But to Meghan's point
about who wants us out
of state building, who wants
us out of the Middle East,
it's not just the
people you might expect.
It is at least in
my organization,
which is 46% under 30
and extremely diverse,
it is the young people of color,
who in part inherit a sort
of post-colonial view that
America in these places has
done nothing but
bad but who also--
they look at the
Middle East and they
see an analogy between American
power oppressing people there
and American power
oppressing people here.
And so to really build the
kind of consensus we want--
and I totally agree with you--
we have to change the
way we talk about it
and think about it.
We need to explain why
actually in the first place
we are just enabling
the people of the region
to rebuild their own countries.
We are not rebuilding anything.
And you said this.
But we have to do
it in a way that
brings us very, very different
group of Americans along.
- Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
We could go on for days, months,
years on the Middle East.
I want to ask a
question on North Korea,
then we're going to
leave you with some hope.
I'm going to ask
the panel what are
you strategically hopeful about
because we don't want to have--
depress this entire audience.
David, until yesterday
morning at 10:00 AM--
and I've been an opponent
of Donald Trump--
I thought he's done
OK on North Korea.
He turned away from war towards
diplomacy, the big summit
June 12, coins minted,
but seriously he
was going to meet him.
Mike Pompeo twice to
Pyongyang first ever
meetings of an American diplomat
with Kim Jong Un, first ever
meetings.
I thought good for Donald Trump.
We should support him in this.
Then it was this letter,
the most unique breakup
letter of all time--
diplomatic breakup
letter-- and are we in?
Are we out?
Is this just part
of the diplomacy?
Is this a tactical move?
Are we going back
to the use of force?
Where are we on North Korea?
- The extraordinary
truth is we don't know.
Covering foreign policy these
last 18 months, whatever it is,
I sometimes liken to vertigo.
You just literally--
it's like falling
through space, something
I never remember feeling
covering Secretary Clinton.
The breakup letter
was a classic,
I mean a classic of
passive aggressive wounded
you said such hurtful
things about me.
I just can't see you anymore.
But maybe we could
get together again.
It's-- just try
reading it as a letter,
like letters that people send.
I think as I stand back and
look at this, the message
that I take is that it
probably isn't a bad thing
that this summit is postponed.
I hope it's not gone
forever and that we're not
back to fire and fury.
But I think we were heading
toward a summit that in a sense
that was burdened
by over-expectation.
The president wanted a
favorable outcome too much
but had planned
for it too little.
The two sides
couldn't really begin
to write the communique
because on the question
of denuclearization, they
had fundamentally different
definitions of what that meant.
And so I think it's not a
terrible thing that people
take a little more time.
I know with great
interest that after
this amazing coy flattering,
threatening letter
from Donald Trump that the North
Koreans responded this morning
their time with a very
measured highroads statement
praising Donald Trump, talking
about the Trump process.
It's been incredibly
important to work with him.
They've really got the
counter-messaging down.
So who can say
where this is going.
But I think a little
more time is appropriate.
I hope the lesson
for this president
is that while there are values
to the disruptive style what
he adopts, suddenly
rearranging chairs,
does create space sometimes,
and we need to be honest.
We can see some of
that with North Korea.
But the disruptive
approach carried
to this extreme
where literally you
don't know from one news cycle
to the next which way are we're
going.
Are we go for the Libyan model?
Are we against it?
Are we for it
again, it literally
has been like that
over the last week.
But in the end, that's
counterproductive.
One thing again--
I come back to
Secretary Clinton--
I watched with great
interest the way
she sometimes used secret
diplomacy in particular
in setting the--
setting sail on our
initiative with Iran
that led to the Iran
nuclear agreement.
But she sent her most
private emissaries to Oman
to begin meetings.
Nobody knew about it.
As a journalist, I'm supposed
to say that's a terrible thing.
And I always want more
information than less,
but I do think Secretary Clinton
understood that sometimes doing
it carefully-- doing it
quietly, not disruptively,
is the way to get the results
that the country wants.
So I hope we're back on
that track with North Korea.
I must say I'm impressed by
Secretary Pompeo's management
of the quiet side of this.
He obviously has the
president's confidence.
If you were going to
make a positive bet,
you'd say that Pompeo
will think strategically
and will end up a little more
time back in this conversation.
- And that's a relatively
hopeful thing to say.
Michele, do you share that,
and when the president
turned towards diplomacy,
I think a lot of us
breathed a sigh of relief
because the military options
you were undersecretary
of defense for policy.
Someday you may be
Secretary of Defense,
just to put you on the spot.
What-- are there
degree of any good--
- We can only hope.
- We all hope this.
We all hope this.
Are there any good
military options?
If we had to go there and
none of us want to go there?
- Yep.
Short answer is no.
But I'll expand.
I agree that I think
this opportunity, which
was an important
opportunity for diplomacy,
fell apart because the
administration was not
serious in its preparation,
really taking the time
to have-- bring in
experts to understand
what do we think Kim Jong Un is
really trying to achieve here?
What do we think we're
trying to achieve?
What are our objectives?
What are we willing to give?
What are they willing to give?
What are we willing
to hold in reserve?
How do you sequence
these things?
The lack of serious
diplomatic preparation
that has been needed in every--
historically in
every single time
where we've had a
breakthrough and success,
it just wasn't done.
So I hope that Mike Pompeo
now has the assignment
to get that going, but
he will have a challenge.
We don't have an ambassador.
We don't have the right
State Department jobs
filled to give him much help.
And you certainly can't
expect this kind of leadership
to come from John Bolton.
So I hope--
I think the best
case is that they
focus on some serious
planning and preparation.
They exert some
message discipline
so they don't have random
officials saying random things
that the North Koreans
have to react to
and that they get back on a more
serious attempt at diplomacy.
And this brings me to
answer to a question
because the alternative is
that if diplomacy truly fails,
this administration
has talked about using
the military option.
And I want to just be
very clear about what
that would look like.
The first thing is we
know that North Korea has
dozens of nuclear weapons.
We know they are distributed
at hidden and underground
facilities.
We know they have hundreds
and hundreds of missiles that
can hit regional allies or
now intercontinental-- hit
United States.
Those are also hidden.
Many are mobile.
There is no military strike
that can denuclearize North
Korea as a military operation.
You may get some of it.
You won't get all of it.
The second thing,
Kim Jong Un's not
going to sit there and take
a large military strike when
it would have to be large
to try to get most of this.
He is going to respond.
How is he likely to respond?
He has tens of thousands of
rock-- short-range rockets
and artillery shells that can
be fired in seconds on their way
to Seoul, the city
with a population of 25
million civilians, including
a lot of Americans.
This-- any kind
of military strike
would almost certainly
quickly escalate
into an actual conflict.
If we actually saw war in
Korea, this is not Iraq.
This is not Afghanistan.
Part of my job was
as undersecretary
was helping the secretary
provide civilian oversight
of war planning.
We went through the Korea
plans dozens of times.
This is a very intensive,
bloody, long war
that the American people
are not prepared for,
and we should never
undertake without exhausting
every possibility including
diplomacy, containment,
and all of the tools
that have worked
for us throughout the Cold War.
Lastly, there's a real
risk of nuclear use.
Kim Jong Un has these
weapons as his survival card.
If we truly in a position
to threaten his regime,
I can't imagine
a situation where
he wouldn't try to use these.
And then we're in the world
of a nuclear conflict.
So we all have to hope
and pray that we get back
on the diplomatic track and that
this time the administration
learned some lessons from
its recent experience
and gets much more
serious about pursuing it.
- Thank you, Michele
[APPLAUSE]
So after Putin, the Middle
East, Syria, Iraq, Kim Jong Un,
we need a little uplifting.
So, Liz, we have
11 minutes left,
and I want to do
two lightning rounds
where I pose two questions,
brief answers from the four
panelists.
The first one is are we living
in the age of pessimism,
social media, the dueling
cable TV channels, all
the pessimism about America.
I'd framed it this way--
my wife Libby is here.
A couple of years ago, she
came to one of my talks here.
She made a huge
mistake of doing that.
And it was about all
of these problems.
And on the way home
here in Cambridge,
I said how'd that go,
and there was a pause.
And she said you're
depressing everybody.
And she said what are
you hopeful about?
Where are the big trend lines?
And that was a really good
observation and question,
so this semester I asked my
class of 75 students from 22
countries don't tell
me what you wish for
but analytically where are the
big positive global trends--
economic,
technological, political
that we can all
try to push forward
on as a human community.
So maybe I'll just go in
reverse order, Anne-Marie,
and start with you.
What are you hopeful about?
- I'm hugely hopeful
because we're
living in an age of renewal.
So two things.
One, everyone here who
has anybody in their life
who is graduating, go buy
a book called Our Towns--
A 100,000-Mile Journey into the
Heart of America by Jim and Deb
Fallows, and I want to
emphasize it's Radcliffe Day.
Jim Fallows, we know him.
He's great.
He's a Harvard grad.
And Deb Fallows, his wife who's
a linguistics PhD from Harvard,
they spent five years flying
around this country going
to large towns, small cities.
Columbus, Ohio to Sioux
Falls to Eastport, Maine,
across this country.
And they tell you
what I have also seen,
that at the national level
I've never been as depressed.
But as-- at the local level,
at the level where people know
each other and know that we're
broken and know that we have
to fix it, as--
they say and they
document people
are coming together and
working together and solving
problems who would never work
together at the national level.
So go and think about
it but go buy it.
And then here's the larger part.
Renewal is the American way.
If you just look back to
the end of the 19th century,
go back and read
your Upton Sinclair.
Go back and look at
the Gini coefficient
for the late 19th
century, the inequality--
the unbelievable inequality
for the historians present.
We-- the-- it was
machine politics.
It was close to violence,
and who renewed us?
It was the folks from
the heartland out.
It was the progressives
and the populace
and people from across
the country, Republicans
and Democrats or more
importantly right and left,
who said we are America.
We have these values.
We fall short, so far
short, but when we do,
we remind ourselves of who
we are and what we stand for,
and we pick ourselves back up.
And we renew this country,
and it is happening now.
[APPLAUSE]
- Like Anne-Marie I refuse to
live in an age of pessimism,
so just quickly two things.
One, obvious this week,
anyone who's here in Cambridge
is just watching our
students graduate.
You cannot help
but be optimistic.
Yesterday I-- with Nick,
we lined the corridor
where our graduates marched
in before the ceremony,
and no matter how
many times I do it
I will never fail to be
moved by their faces,
by the enthusiasm that they all
have for going out and making
the world a different place.
So if you're ever feeling down,
just pop on a video of that.
Second, more in
the policy side, I
would say I'm optimistic about
the age of energy abundance.
So if we were
meeting 10 years ago,
we could have got
into a conversation
about potential
nodes of conflict,
and we might have focused
on energy scarcity
as being one of those nodes.
Because 10 years ago, the
global energy landscape
looked completely different
from what it looks like today.
Today we really are
living in a world
where people are worried
about energy rightly
from a perspective
of climate change
and other potential
environmental issues
but much less
worried about energy
from the perspective of
being a source of conflict.
So I have a former colleague
who in 2006 said he could not
imagine any future
scenario that did not
involve conflict between
the United States and China
over energy.
Nobody will make that
statement today because China
and the US are not
competing for energy.
In fact, China is
exporting energy to--
no, the US is exporting energy
to China, pretty remarkable.
And there are a number
of other examples
I could give you how this
new energy landscape actually
provides some opportunities
for more peaceful engagement,
be it from undermining one of
Russia's real potent foreign
policy tools to actually
potentially creating reasons
for new relationships
such as between Israelis
and their Arab neighbors because
Israel has huge new natural gas
finds, a resource that its
neighbors really need and want.
So that's one good
reason to be optimistic--
two good reasons.
- David.
- I'll also offer
two quick reasons.
I'm optimistic because we
still live in a country
where citizens get to decide
what kind of government
they want.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm not happy about the choices
that people sometimes make,
but-- and I want people to
fight to preserve their ability
to choose despite
outside interference
and apprise that citizenship.
But we still are
special in that respect.
Second, and this
sounds so corny,
but I'm optimistic
every time I walk
into the newsroom
of the Washington
Post and any other
major news organization.
[APPLAUSE]
Sometimes in my
business you wonder
what's the point of it all?
Do we really make a difference?
I don't think anybody
in the Washington Post,
the New York Times, any
of these organizations
thinks that today we know
we make a difference,
and we're really trying
hard to tell the truth.
- Here here.
[APPLAUSE]
- I, too, refuse to
be too pessimistic.
So a couple of
things give me hope
even though they've
come out of very tragic,
upsetting circumstances.
The one first is
the mobilization
of women in this country
in the #MeToo movement
and the example to finally end
behavior that should have been
seen as completely unacceptable
decades ago but to--
and to hold people accountable
and to change norms
and behaviors and expectations.
It just gives me a great hope,
and it's actually inspiring.
I'm on the board
of CARE and NGO,
and it's actually inspiring
now a global #MeToo
movement, which
is just incredible
for women around the world.
Second is young people.
Look at how the
students of Parkland
and all over this
country have stood up
and said this has to stop.
This gun violence has
to stop, and we're not
going to stop until it changes.
And lastly look at how
many women and how many
young people are like
first responders running
toward the flames.
They are going to go run for
office and change the system.
[APPLAUSE]
- So my 75 students said
poverty alleviation,
the greatest in the
history of the world last
30 years, global health,
the eradication of polio
in two to three years,
malaria in 20 to 25.
They hope for technology, too.
They see the double edge on
AI, on quantum computing,
on gene editing, but they
see that's a hopeful tool.
And lastly-- and this was
really high on the class poll--
leadership opportunities
for women, 75 students
from 22 countries.
So, Liz, can we do a lightning
round of 30 seconds each
because the last question,
Madame Secretary, is about you?
And it's about you.
You don't have to
say anything now.
To all of you in
30 seconds, what
do you most admire
about Secretary Clinton?
- Yes, Anne-Marie.
- I've got books
on that subject.
What I admire about
Secretary Clinton
is that she has an
extraordinarily expansive
vision of how America
should be in the world.
I thought-- I'll
make a confession--
that I was going to teach
her more than she taught me.
I'd done-- been doing
foreign policy for 30 years,
and she was
relatively new to it.
She taught me to
think about a world
not only in terms of
states and diplomacy
and coercion and defense,
all the things you've heard,
but also a world in which we
equally focus on the people
and on poverty and education
and health and resource security
and food security and
anti-corruption, what
makes a difference to people
how they live every day.
Our security in this world
and our morality in this world
lies in that just as much
as classic diplomacy.
Secretary Clinton
taught me that,
and it is a lesson that will
guide the rest of my life.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
Two points in 30 seconds.
So first is an idea
and one is a policy.
What I admire most is
the big idea behind I
think everything that we've
seen Secretary Clinton do,
especially on the
world stage, and that
is that the objective
of US foreign policy
is to make the world
a better place.
Reading back over speeches
she's made, in 2013,
she said to the Council
on Foreign Relations
we, the United States, are the
force for progress, prosperity,
and peace, unabashedly
embracing that role of the US
and the responsibility
that comes with that.
So I have-- I admired that
and I admire that today
more than ever.
On policy I would say one
country that surprisingly we
didn't talk about is China.
And this is a very--
this is the would say
the most important
bilateral relationship
that the US has,
maybe the most or certainly
the most important
bilateral relationship in
the world and obviously very,
very complex.
And I feel like
Secretary Clinton,
she really understood
the importance of that
and the challenge that
China posed both in terms
of its power and its ambitions.
But I also felt like her
approach towards China
recognized that it is essential
we find an accommodation--
accommodation is a
wrong word I guess--
essential that we find
a way to work with China
and that it is possible
for us to do this.
We have sufficient
common interest
that we can find a way.
And that I think is so critical
to the US success in the world
and really to global
success going forward.
And that is something
which is easier said
than actually implemented,
and I give her a lot of credit
for advancing those ideas.
[APPLAUSE]
- I'm a journalist, so I
don't want to get too gee
whiz an answer here.
So I'll just say two things.
In covering Secretary
Clinton for a long time,
I think she consistently
gets the big things right,
and that matters.
She's strategic.
And the second thing
is that she's tough.
There is a reason why Vladimir
Putin was so determined
that she not be our president.
[APPLAUSE]
- I have a long list, so I'm
going to try to be quick.
Number one, Hillary Clinton
is an amazing role model
not only for women
but for any American
who wants to serve
their country.
Her leadership, her
toughness, her resilience,
this woman cannot be stopped
from serving her country.
[APPLAUSE]
And second, her
strategic focus, as you
said, whether it was having
the foresight to realize
that the most consequential
region for the United
States for America in terms of
our prosperity and our security
long term was going
to be Asia and we
needed to start moving more
of our strategic bandwidth
towards Asia, whether
it was the insight
of the power of empowering
women for every dimension
of foreign policy
and development
for us and for around the world.
And the last thing
I'll say is I've never
seen anyone more
fully understand
how to integrate the different
instruments of American power,
the military, sanctions,
economics, trade in service
of diplomacy to
achieve strategic ends,
it was like a master class
in the use of American power
and influence.
And we all had a great
deal to learn from her,
so thank you for your
example and your service.
[APPLAUSE]
- And, Madam Secretary, I
admire your faith and diplomacy.
We need that leadership.
I admire your courage in
Teddy Roosevelt's arena.
And I admire your resilience
and faith in our country.
Thank you for everything
you've done for us.
[APPLAUSE]
- And I want to add
my thanks to Nick
and the panelists for a truly
fascinating conversation.
[APPLAUSE]